dicen que una imagen vale más que mil
palabras y está tomada por el fotógrafo
flavio gasperini ciertamente cuenta la
historia de un desgarrador rescate en el
mediterráneo' en las primeras horas de
la mañana del lunes
este es el ocean by king el barco de
rescate de inmigrantes que pertenece a
la ong s oeste mediterránea en sólo unas
horas 369 personas la mayoría egipcios
eritreos y nacionales bengalís fueron
rescatados de un bote en aguas libias a
los voluntarios les tomó cinco horas
subir a todo el mundo a bordo este
discípulo meiners azul y un tercio de
ellos o en mi granja el 18 mujeres
algunas embarazadas algunas personas se
encuentran en un estado muy vulnerable
statewatch mode en este gran número se
suma a los 200 migrantes que el barco ya
había rescatado en días anteriores 572
migrantes que se encuentran ahora a
bordo forzando al barco a dirigirse
hacia el norte para tratar de
desembarcar en un puerto europeo
sí ahora mismo la prioridad es
desembarcar los en un lugar seguro de
acuerdo el derecho marítimo
los estados costeros ofrecer un lugar
seguros están exhaustos y traumatizados
por lo que han vivido en libia y se
encuentran inquietos por no ser
devueltos de nuevo a libia no tuviesen
baxu libia si el barco vuelve a europa
no habrá más buques de rescate en el
mediterráneo' en el punto álgido del
verano un momento de altos flujos de
emigración por la tranquilidad de las
aguas otros tres barcos incluido uno que
pertenece a médicos sin fronteras están
actualmente bloqueados en italia por
razones administrativas